日本企業在公司裡自己跑的深層式AI用的幾乎都是中國的模型。
今年9月,在各大報社和電視臺合組的日本記者俱樂部,一位教授這樣說,
他叫佐藤一郎,是日本國立情報學研究所的教授。
這是文部科學省底下的國家研究所,有點像臺灣中研院的資訊所。
日本大學共用的學術網路、論文、資料庫都歸他管。
日本的開源大型語言模型LLMJP也是他做的。
他本人的專長是讓AI跑起來的系統軟體
也替日本數位廳審政策和預算
大多數學習模型是中國式的
特別多的是
阿里巴巴所製造的學習模型
有很多
籤問是開源模型
在公司內跑
資料不會送出去
問答時間主持人就從這一點切入
先提了一件事
今年6月
Anthropic的Fable 5才上線三天
就因為美國商務部的指令全面停用
停了快三個禮拜
他問
這樣看來
一般國家和企業
是不是用開放模型比較保險
首先,由於開放或關閉的情況下,如您所指出的突然供應被停止的情況下,
我認為關閉型是危險的。
關閉型的情況下,也有另一方面的情況。
在Fable之前,大家可以想起MUTOS時期的騷動。
MUTOS是聖聖AI在安斯洛比克中活動的。
用MUTOS去找出軟件的脆弱性和容易受到細胞攻擊的地方
這令日本政府中心發生了很大的騷擾
但在封鎖模式的時期 另一個問題是
使用MUTOS時 要把軟件進入安斯洛比克
需要入力
例如銀行或電力公司在公司內運行的軟件
即使有軟件的脆弱性
只是透過網絡才能夠進行智慧攻擊
但為了檢測AI的脆弱性
通過軟件或入力
因此入力受到的方法是可以根據詳細搜索的
當然這是一個利益
但通常在網絡內的攻擊中
你會發現無法找到的脆弱性
我想說的是
你可能相信Anthropic
這並沒有保證能夠教導整個軟件的脆弱性
以此來看,
我們從技術家的角度來看,
在IT時期的日本,
在IT方面被稱為民族地區
職民主義的日本必須向領導國提供人權
所以一見之下是不錯的說話
但其實是很危險的
所以應該做的事情是
例如是包裝軟件或是開放軟件
在外面出現的軟件上
是有危險的
所以可以使用NITOS調查
但是在技術家的角度來說,
從技術家的角度來說,
我認為是很不可能的。
在這種意義上,
如果MITOS是開放型,
在銀行或電力公司中使用的話,
我認為是很危險的。
下一位記者問到主權AI。
法國的Mistro喊出要做不靠美國的AI。
他問日本做不做得到
但是這些能夠做到的文章只是簡單的文章,就像在網上的文章一樣
比如說會談的文章,這些文章終於不能做了
因為這些文章必須用人海戰術來製作,
所以並不是很簡單的
未來可能會很困難,
因為日本的戰略,
不論是美國的戰略,
中國的戰略,
無論是哪個國家的戰略,
在日本使用生成AI時,
希望要求的質素的生成AI在不發生供給停止的情況下,
要如何穩定地確保。
我認為這是一個選擇的方法
因此,我們應該怎麼做呢?
例如,我們可以判斷AI的品質和基準
我們可以判斷世上的AI是否滿足這些基準
如果沒有這樣的方法,
我認為這是不可能的現實問題
在他看來
海耀做的日本企業很多
真正自己動手做的幾乎沒有
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多